a million dollars
[Music]
yes that's the Barenaked Ladies Classic
if I had a million dollars and it's one
of the million reasons why barenaked
ladies has become an iconic Canadian
group 30 years 15 studio albums more
than 14 million copies sold 8 Juno's
multiple Grammy nominations and today
the ladies are adding another accolade
to their amazing careers entry into the
Canadian Music Hall of Fame yeah Carlos
it certainly looks like everybody will
be there so yes BNL will be reunited
again temporarily at least with Stephen
Paige joining us former bandmates to
accept the tremendous honor at the Junos
and March ok I'm so excited we need like
a drumroll Freddy are you gonna bring
the family or gonna bring everyone with
you that was involved for Barenaked
Ladies well Stephen Paige come along
with you guys we're we're working out
all the details right now Steve we'll
definitely be there for the induction
with us which is great but yeah my whole
family's coming out too it's really huge
how did you find out like that my
parents forget God you can never forget
God how did you find out well we got a
phone call from our manager and then the
first thing I did when the shock wore
off is I googled
like past inductees and I went and
looked at the list and that's when I got
really freaked out
well what does it mean just get that
kind of recognition after guess it's
been 30 years together making incredible
music would we be still continuing on
and happy and making great music for a
number of years now if we haven't
haven't got this award yes but getting
it sure feels nice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is
[Applause]
we have people coming out to see us that
talked about the fact that their parents
first brought them to see us when they
were in grade school and now they're
bringing their kids to see us that
continuum is pretty cool you know really
going for the newborn so we're trying to
get as fresh-baked as possible yeah
[Music]
is there a particular highlight for you
well when I scored the ten points
against the Boston Bruins in 1990 you're
mixing yourself up with Daryl oh sorry I
thought was the Hockey Hall of Fame here
guys no okay sorry one day one day well
there's big big concerts I took my kids
to see the Justin Bieber documentary the
first one he released and the whole
story arc is about him going to finally
sell out Madison Square Garden and I
remember saying to my kids after you
know I did that once just to kind of put
it in perspective me as dad oh yeah he
plays music how do you guys party what's
the best way to party with the bernanke
ladies we like to eat yes surprise so
you really get down you go really
yeah barenaked ladies parties in the
tabloids the next day he od'd on
appetizers